les travaux sur la route départementale
26 entre pierrefonds et bois d'olive
sont terminées en terme de circulation
c'est l'artère la plus fréquentée du
réseau routier départemental dans le sud
c'est très important d'aménager cette
partie sud notamment de pierrefonds qui
est un point stratégique par rapport à
la circulation aux heures d'affluence et
par jour c'est vingt mille véhicules qui
passent sur cette route entre
pierrefonds ravine des cabris bois
d'olive et les autres villes
l'aménagement consiste à améliorer et à
sécuriser les accès à la civis et aux
différents services ainsi que le
cheminement des piétons sur ce secteur
le revêtement de la chaussée soumis à un
fort trafic poids lourds est également
renforcée afin d'améliorer le confort et
la sécurité des usagers
des aménagements ont été faits pour
sécuriser toute la partie où il ya le
plus de monde qui se rendent nous sommes
ici près d'un arrêt de bus près d'une
école aussi et de nombreux enfants pas
de descente de cette route pour se
rendre à l'école et c'est vrai que une
partie cette route étant
très pratique et énormément de personnes
qui se rendent deux sur l'arrivée du
cabri le montant des travaux s'élève à
533 1500 euros financés à hauteur de 86%
par le département et à 14% parle assez
lisse le département bénéficie d'un
budget de 25 millions d'euros par an
pour aménager et sécuriser les routes
départementales de la ring sur tout le
département le budget route
aménagement des abords routiers a été
doublé sur cette mandature et nous en
sommes créés content
remercions les collègues qui s'occupe
des routes d'avoir bien voulu favoriser
les points noirs sur notre canton
d'autres points noirs aussi sur la
ravine des cabris et la ligne des
bambous seront aussi aménagés par la
suite et je pense que ce projet de
mandature
sur les routes la la la réfection des
raids a été radié est vraiment très
utile
ce projet de réaménagement n'est qu'un
début dans le sud l'objectif étant en
partie de sécuriser les routes
départementales de plus en plus
fréquentes et je pense que pour cette
mandature
on a bien pu
les tenants et aboutissants des besoins
de la population
aussi at-elle on est en début de mandat
mais je pense qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres
choses à faire et
dans le projet il ya un planning qui va
être d'élucider au fur et à mesure sur
ce projet de mandature 2017 2021 700
millions d'euros sont consacrés à la
commande publique pour l'entretien des
routes mais aussi pour la construction
de collèges la rénovation des bâtiments
départementaux ou encore le
développement des réseaux hydrauliques